en dépit de ce que dit la science depuis
plus de 2000 ans la terre est plate
aux yeux de millions d'êtres humains
autour du globe selon des sondages
récents 9% des français 7 % des
brésiliens et près de 12 millions
d'américains croient en la possibilité
d'une terre absolument plate qui
ressemblerait à ceux ci disque plat
bordé par l'antarctique transformer en
infranchissable mur de glace
cette terre plate est recouverte d'un
dôme qui maintient l'atmosphère en place
et autour duquel tourne le soleil les
autres planètes et le reste de l'univers
et les astronautes dans tout ça des
acteurs au coeur d'un vaste complot
selon les plates east notre
collaborateur l'historien laurent turcot
a récemment goûter à leur médecine
laurent turcot question de bien camper
le sujet
toi même le sol du le vécu de près de
vue un peu c'est quoi quelles sont ces
théories et elles sont les personnes
aussi derrière ce mouvement là oui j'ai
pu le voir parce que j'ai publié une
vidéo sur ma chaîne youtube
ça s'appelle la terre plate médiévale
pour leur montrer qu'on n'a jamais pensé
à l'époque du moyen-age que la terre
était plate
ben non on n'a jamais cru que la terre
au moyen-âge il quand j'ai publié la
vidéo j'ai vu plein plate east au québec
comme en france commenté ma vidéo en
disant que je suis payé par la nasa que
tout ce que je suis il faut que je suis
une forme de complotiste et que tout le
monde sait que la terre est plate qui en
a qui se lance dans des explications
mathématiques incompréhensible ce qui
est intéressant de voir ses clips la tis
non seulement ils sont présents québec
mais ils sont très présents et très
agressif
alors voilà pour le portrait actuel le
profit finalement des plates east tels
que te plus percevoir
mais si on remonte à la source
historique les débuts la mort de ce
discours là de cette division là pour
employer le terme théorie dès
l'antiquité on le savait qu'elle était
ronde
même quand on regarde dans les
représentations médiévales aux 16e et
17e au 18e
tout le monde le savait le consensus est
que oui ça existait déjà dans cosi
encore comment ça se fait que des gens
ont plaqué cette vision là du moyen-âge
au 19e siècle
on commence à imaginer un moyen âge que
jamais existé un moyen âge
obscurantistes ce qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on voulait expliquer la renaissance
la renaissance c'est la re découverte de
l'antiquité donc on aurait deux périodes
lumineuse l'antiquité et la renaissance
qu'en plein milieu
on a inventé une période noire qui n'a
jamais été comme ça qui sont les
historiens quand on arrive on dit on
veut défaire ces lieux communs et ses
mythes là mais là on attaque les gens
dans leur conception et les 10 oui mais
j'ai toujours cru que c'était noir le
moyen-âge plus on leur dit ben non c'est
pas comme ça mais quand on arrive face
aux plates east ils disent non seulement
elle était plate mais l'a toujours été
platement 10 ou attention lorsqu'un
autre niveau là c'est quand même assez
absurde de voir que ces gens là ont le
crachoir eagle très fort la grande
question c'est de savoir est-ce qu'il
faut débattre avec ces gens là
est-ce qu'il faut leur apporter des
preuves ou est-ce qu'il faut les écouter
je pense que la meilleure technique cpo
de les écouter les laisser de côté parce
que ce qu'ils disent il faut et les
légitimer sa offert que la connerie va
se répandre et plus la connerie serait
pas plus l'intellectuel qui lui
travaille pendant des années et
marginalisés et c'est là qu'on voit la
grande perte de confiance qu'on a envers
les institutions envers les médias puis
envers les intellectuels et là on un
problème fondamental comment on le
conçoit c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire
en ce moment je suis pas sûr que ça va
marcher on sent pas qu'après ça on va se
faire ramasser sur les réseaux sociaux
mais quand même c'est une job d'exister
pizza ce que vous dites est faux
nous avons raison vous avez tort point
final à un moment donné l'intellectuel
doit capable de dire ça c'est pas de la
science et les platines
pas de la science
[Musique]
on analyse la plus nos images de verre
plat tu penses que les gens pensent le
dôme
la terre est ce qu'elle est ronde doit
les platines pour moi et j'espère que
c'est vrai la terre la latte seconde
section cross m'attend c'est ça marche
pas qu'est ce qu'on en a pas c'est ce
que ça vous inquiète de savoir 5 mai
simple guitare voix ce qui est mauvais
ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'est ce qui
fait en sorte que les gens peuvent
continuer à penser c'est bien on
s'entend le consensus sur le fait
qu'apple soir on nous classe et faites
le en un consensus l errance
et le consensus scientifique aussi est
indéniable mais justement quel regard
portent les scientifiques sur les plates
east souche à stenay on se retrouve
entouré de globes terrestres pour parler
de ces fameuse théorie laxiste qui
connaissent une résurgence des théories
qui ont été façonnées au fil du temps
mais qui constamment depuis des lunes
sans jeu de mots ont été confrontés à de
la vraie si on fait ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que l'idée que la terre est plate
c'est une idée qui est très ancienne en
fait les premiers humains considéré que
la terre était plate jusqu'à je vous
dirais l'époque des penseurs grecs donc
les philosophes grecs par exemple
eratosthène a mesuré le diamètre de la
terre est arrivé qu'une valeur très très
précise à plus ou moins 10 % avec
simplement des bâtons plantées dans le
sol en mesurant la longueur des ombres
on parle du 3e siècle avant notre ère
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'assez extraordinaire et puis je vous
dirais que après ça en galilée copernic
kepler et les autres sont arrivés au 15e
au xvième siècle l'idée que la terre
était ronde était bien établie et est
bien comprise par tous était acceptée
par tous
et puis effectivement on voit cette
résurgence sur internet des théories
vous là que la terre est plate
ce qui tient absolument pas debout bien
sûr mais il ya quand même des congrès
qui se tient quand même de plus en plus
de gens qui sont intéressés par ces
idées là c'est assez troublant a fait
alors déjà des démonstrations je les
avais évoqué quelques jeunes d'entre
elles à tout le moins ce qui prouve ce
fait l'indéniable mais en un courriel
aux mondiaux on peut faire plein
d'observation qui demande que la terre
est ronde par exemple vous êtes sur le
bord de l'eau vous voyez un bateau
arrivé si vous prenez des jumelles
vous allez voir le sommet des mâts avant
que la coque apparaissent
parce que le bateau est en partie sous
l'horizon
un truc super le fun que vous pouvez
faire c'est observer coucher de soleil
au pied d'un édifice en hauteur avec une
instance heures et puis dès que vous
voyez que le soleil se couche à
l'horizon vous sautez dans l'ascenseur
vous montez le plus rapidement possible
au dernier étage et vous retournez à la
fenêtre et vous allez voir le soleil à
nouveau face à va il faut faire se lever
le soleil se couche quand même assez
rapidement mais si vous le faites
suffisamment rapidement vous avez
capable de constater que au moment où
vous étiez au sol le soleil a disparu
sous l'horizon mais puisque la terre est
ronde en vous et levant suffisamment
rapidement vous êtes capable de le voir
à nouveau alors il ya pleins pleins
d'observation qui démontre que la terre
est ronde
mais tous n'y croit possible oui et puis
à chaque fois on s'ajuste entre les
plates east s'ajuste niveau d'une autre
théorie pour contrecarrer les autres
mais ont souvent l'impression que les la
communauté scientifique lèvent le nez
sur le fait de confronter ces personnes
manquent on s'attarde même pas ce
discours là qui pourtant gagne des
extrêmes quand je les fais beaucoup à
l'époque face à la résurgence de
l'ufologie les extraterrestres qui ont
visité
j'ai eu des débats avec des ufologues j
du débat avec des gens qui croyaient
sincèrement que des extraterrestres nous
visiter et c'est un dialogue de sourds
un peu la même chose avec les plate
c'est un peu la même chose avec les gens
qui se méfie des vaccins on est rendu à
un niveau chez ces gens là qui frise la
croyance qui frise la foi et aucun
argument rationnel qui va être capable
de les convaincre parce qu'on est
vraiment sur des niveaux de discussion
ou de conversations qui sont
incompatibles
alors je comprends les scientifiques de
pause s'attarder à ceux d'une part parce
que ça bouffe du temps de manière
extraordinaire pas d'autre part et pas
de subventions et de chercher pour faire
des recherches sur le fait que la terre
est ronde
on le sait alors les scientifiques
préfèrent et avec raison se concentrer
sur leurs travaux qui sont
subventionnées pour produire des
nouvelles connaissances
alors qu'on vois pas vraiment l'intérêt
de se pencher sur un truc qui est
démontrée depuis plus de 2000 ans
musée saint jacques est un des rares
êtres humains avoir vu notre planète la
terre de là bas à quoi ressemble la
terre vue de l'espace et touchant
comment c'est beau les imaginez vous la
scène ont enlevé deux mortels de
l'espace wilaya la terre ronde la terre
une boule ronde qui flotte dans le vide
et c'est notre vaisseau spatial nous
sommes tous des astronautes sur cette
bille qui flotte dans le vide est faux
on a vraiment la responsabilité d'en
prendre soin c'est une image là
indélébile merci infiniment merci